et sur ce plateau kader abderrahim vient
de nous rejoindre il est chercheur à
l'iris l'institut des relations
internationales stratégiques spécialiste
du maghreb de l'islamisme et auteur de
géopolitique de l'état islamique aux
éditions eyrolles bonjour kader
abderrahim et rejoue d'être avec nous
donc ce sommet international vient de
s'ouvrir à l'instant on a vu une
première rencontre entre reggio tayyip
erdogan et et vladimir poutine donc
on a entendu les premières déclarations
qu'est ce qu'il faut en retenir la
fermeté en tout cas du côté turc
et puis fermeté également du président
russe qui visiblement n'a pas digéré
encore le revers que lui a fait subir le
maréchalat tard puisqu'il avait quitté
moscou sans apposer sa signature au bas
du cessez-le-feu alors qu'il était
invité et qui là ils étaient conviés à
moscou précisément pour rencontrer
monsieur fayat savage de premier
ministre reconnu internationalement en
tout cas par la nation unie et donc on
voit qu'aujourd'hui une pression plus
importante encore qu'ils exercent et on
le peut le noter
avec la présence du secrétaire général
de l'onu et des états unis
will est représentée par mes compères le
secrétaire d'état américain
est-ce que
le cessez-le-feu la trêve peuvent
véritablement avoir lieu sur le terrain
entre khalifa haftar qui contrôlent
l'est du pays et fayçal sa rage qui lui
est donc le premier ministre du
gouvernement d'union nationale vous
l'avez dit reconnu par un par l'onu mais
mais contesté quand même d'ailleurs
difficile d'y voir clair puisqu'il est
soutenu par ankara soutenu
officiellement aux yeux de la communauté
internationale mais il accuse la france
notamment de soutenir à demi-mot khalifa
haftar notamment écoutez je pense que si
on veut vraiment être efficace dans ce
dossier à l'instar de ce que disait
depuis de ce que dit depuis plusieurs
mois maintenant
l'émissaire des nations unies raza là
mais il faut faire respecter l'embargo
sur les ventes d'armes à la libye
je pense que ça passera par là d'autant
que les nations unies viennent de
renouveler de reconduire la résolution
24 centrait sur l'embargo des ventes
d'armes à la libye
comme en juin dernier comme ça se fait
régulièrement et en tout cas
annuellement
donc je crois que c'est un des points
majeurs qui va être discuté à berlin
au cours de cette conférence et si on
veut que les deux protagonistes des deux
principaux belligérants haftar et sa
rage puissent se parler pour parvenir à
un compromis politique afin de cesser
des combats
il faut que cela passe par un respect
impératif du cessez-le-feu et ensuite
ils se parleront et parviendront à un
compromis parce que ce qui est en jeu en
réalité c'est le partage du pouvoir
aujourd'hui le maréchalat tard contrôle
plus de 80% du territoire libyen et je
crois qu'il n'est pas prêt de renoncer
aux positions qu'il a acquise s'il n'a
pas une véritable représentativité à
l'intérieur du futur gouvernement libyen
vous dites que l'un des enjeux c'est le
partage du pouvoir
mais alors comment expliquer et qu'il y
ait paris rome berlin évidemment qui
organise cette conférence moscou en
quart à d'ailleurs y'a pas tunis et il
ya par abba non plus mais mais comment
expliquer une telle internationalisation
de ce conflit en libye les européens
disent officiellement que c'est pour
lutter contre le djihadisme et contre
les vagues migratoires mais ce qui a pas
derrière toutes les ressources
énergétiques
évidemment et a toujours des arrière
pensées politiques
dans ce genre d'affaires et de dossier
singulièrement libye il ya beaucoup
d'autres acteurs qui ne sont pas
présents à berlin et qu'on aurait pu
citer et qui sont des acteurs absolument
essentiel je pense à l'egypte
aux émirats arabes unis qu'il vivre
aujourd'hui en violation de l'embargo
beaucoup d'âme au marshall avt à
l'arabie saoudite le soudan d'une
certaine manière
l'algérie l'italie la france la
grande-bretagne
tous ces pays sont impliqués à des
titres divers et pour des raisons
diverses
l'union européenne elle elle est très
divisé et donc l avance en rangs
dispersés sur le dossier libyen
à présent on va voir si à berlin y
parviennent à obtenir des deux
belligérants un une vérité un véritable
respect de l'embargo et d'eux qu'ils se
parlent enfin juste l'un et l'autre
comme vous le savez refuse de se
rencontrer ce qui est quand même assez
compliqué et difficile lorsqu'on veut
pas revenir alors ce qu'on veut mettre
en place un dialogue politique pour
parvenir à un compromis
donc dans l'immédiat il faut il y aura
des pressions diplomatiques des uns et
des autres le président poutine soutient
plutôt le mage la fta le président
arthur soutient plutôt failli à sa rage
à tripoli
donc l'un et l'autre ont décidé de
confier de faire converger leur position
même si elles sont divergents pour
parvenir sur le plan diplomatique un
accord il ya eu une tentative la semaine
dernière à moscou cette semaine à moscou
pardon qui s'est avéré être un échec
et aujourd'hui avec la pression qui
s'exerce sur les deux belligérants
je pense que ça va devenir 2
plus en plus difficile pour eux encore
une fois ce sera évidemment une première
étape mais insuffisant pour ramener
réellement la paix en libye
justement est-ce que la libye peut-elle
être une nouvelle syrie c'est la
question concept qu'on se pose
évidemment aujourd'hui il ya tellement
15 à 20 pays sont directement ou
indirectement impliqués dans la guerre
en cours en libye
deuxième guerre civile quand même un
avec l'offensive du maréchal haftar
lancé en avril 2019 pour parvenir à
faire tomber la capitale tripoli
il n'y est pas parvenu mais quoi qu'il
arrive il ya eu des dizaines de milliers
de personnes qui ont quitté pour fuir
les combats
et aujourd'hui le pays est dans un chaos
indescriptible à la fois sur le plan
politique mais également diplomatique
vous posez la question à l'heure à
l'accasion des pas répondu mais que je
n'ai pas oublié sur les enjeux
énergétiques
évidemment il ya eu un accord qui a été
signé le 27 novembre dernier entre le
président turc et le premier sa rage sur
l'exploitation de nappes gaz ya qui se
trouve au large de la libye en
méditerranée ça a été très mal perçue
par les autres partenaires égyptiens
grecs chypriotes israélien parce que la
méditerranée est aujourd'hui recèle des
richesses en hydrocarbures considérable
que ce soit du gaz ou du pétrole et elle
pourrait devenir au sud-est de la de
l'eau de l'union européenne elle
pourrait redevenir une pourvoyeuse de
gaz qui est une énergie d'avenir parce
que c'est une énergie propre
donc ça constitue également l'un des
enjeux politiques de ce dossier c'est le
mot de la fin merci kader abderrahim
d'avoir à répéter la question je
rappelle que vous êtes chercheur à
l'iris et auteur de géopolitique de
l'état islamique aux éditions eyrolles